25 يوليو ، بعد العام المركزي لحزب الشعب ، عادة التوسيع الطارئ في مبنى حكومة فون فير
رئيس حزب العمال الكوري ورئيس B1 الأم الوطنية لجمهورية كوريا الشعبية الديمقراطية
إنه أعظم عمل في زمن جمهورية كوريا الشعبية الديمقراطية.
شارك الرفيق Kim Seong-han ، القائد الاستشاري لـ Daum وعدم وجود مفتشية وطنية ، في الجدول 2
أنت رحلت
وشارك في الجريمة مرشحو المكتب السياسي للجنة المركزية لحزب العمال الكوري.
نتيجة لمكافحة الفساد ، شارك أعضاء جونيبر الأقوياء في الأذن المركزية.
أصبح الفرع المركزي لمجلس الوزراء عضوًا في اللجنة التنفيذية مع المسؤولين الإداريين للحزب ودوجو الدجاج.
المشاركة في Do Cook Leading Employee Responsibility Volume 1 Jeongyeon Office
رقاقة تعمل مقدس اجتماعات قيصر الرفاق وفقا لولاية المكتب السياسي لمرافقة
فعلتها